security checks like this one in
Kandahar help keep ordinary citizens
safe from terrorist attacks officers put
their lives on the line checking car
seats for hidden explosives and when
police do catch suicide bombers they
themselves can become the victims
Afghanistan security force is still
number 350,000 roughly one percent of
the population almost all of them have
received training from NATO I'm glad
that we're taking over responsibility
now our police officers are sons of this
nation they'll serve us better than
foreigners the foreigners always acted
in their own interests he done
Afghanistan's troops are often poorly
equipped and the pay is meager there are
fears that will tempt soldiers to accept
bribes from Afghan warlords leaders at
the handover ceremony in Kabul painted a
picture of optimism President Hamid
Karzai announced representatives of his
government would meet with the Taliban
on neutral ground in Qatar hours later
the Taliban officially opened a Qatari
office NATO said Pakistan would also be
crucial to Afghanistan's future we
encourage the Pakistani authorities to
engage positively in ensuring long-term
peace and stability in the region the
lawless border region between
Afghanistan and Pakistan remains a base
for militants and just a few kilometers
from the ceremony the danger they still
posed was apparent another suicide
attack claimed the lives of three
civilians
you